the people of ethiopia have been around
for a long long time this region has
been populated for thousands of years
but the country's ancient heritage isn't
immediately apparent in the capital
addis ababa
[Music]
yet there is a place in this city where
some of ethiopia's most precious
artifacts are stored
and they have recently received some
very important additions three of them
came from the netherlands yeah and
certain of them from britain okay
we were taken to the fourth floor of the
national museum storeroom and they
unlocked a cabinet in the corner
inside we found cultural treasures
looted by british soldiers in the 19th
century oh wow what what is that it's a
shield it's a shield yes
and was that used in the battle of
magdala yeah
earlier this year these items were put
up for auction by the descendants of the
troops who took them
but ethiopian diplomats intervened and
negotiated their return to the capital
you can see the name of the captain who
who took it
the british soldier who grabbed these
buffalo horn beakers topped them in
silver and engraved his name
is it disappointing that family members
are doing this they're trying to make
money out of
stolen items yeah disappointing
disappointing not because that is that
particular family auctioned them but
because these are part of ethiopian
treasures which auctioned in the outside
world yeah the battle of magdala in 1868
is viewed by many ethiopians as a
catastrophe
facing defeat by the british army
emperor theodore ii took his own life
and his possessions were expropriated
some of them ended up in museums and
others ended up in private collections
of the soldiers and the soldiers also
when they found theodore's body uh they
took cut bits of his hair and rip bits
of his his shirt and
souvenirs
and in fact quite recently the imperial
war museum returned restituted a uh a
piece of his hair
the then minister of culture went on a
visit and she
pointed out to them that it was
not really such a nice thing to do to
have
human remains on display
in europe and the uk people feel less
comfortable now about cultural treasures
that were plundered at gunpoint and it's
prompted some to act a cambridge college
has returned one of the famed benin
bronzes stolen by british soldiers back
in 1897
and the french president emmanuel macron
says he's prepared to return all
artifacts that were taken without
consent
but such a policy would devastate
collections in institutions like the
british museum british cultural
institutions museums have provided a
safe space
to both preserve and display
these items that they have essentially
ensured their survival that's correct
but let's not forget that um manuscripts
have been kept in ethiopia from the
sixth century and uh you know they even
had a system where they had cats that
were um
there to protect the churches and the
manuscripts from rats
ethiopians have not forgotten about the
theft of a set of christian plaques at
the battle of magdala
each church in this country has one
they're called tabits but the tablets
removed from the battlefield are of deep
historical and holy importance the
public at large now still frequently
asked
primarily the tablets and that is very
sacred project very suckered the tablets
which represent the ark of the covenant
are now held in a storeroom in the
british museum and 20 years of
negotiations has not won their release
it's uh even it's a it's
really just shocking
these artifacts come with their own
unique history a record of theft that
cannot be ignored
and pressure will build on those who
hold them to return them
it may be the best way to learn from the
past
john sparks sky news in addis ababa